in spite of all the flying dragons Game
of Thrones is one of the most serious
shows in TV history and with all that
tension on screen the show's cast of
award-winning actors from all over the
world simply has to break the tension
from time to time that results in some
very charming
if surprising bloopers that will change
the way you watch these scenes in Game
of Thrones
Tyrion tongue-twister Peter Dinklage has
won two Emmys and a Golden Globe for his
portrayal of Tyrion Lannister the witty
less love child of one of the most
powerful clans in Westeros Dinklage has
excellent diction honed over a long
career in front of cameras and yet
certain words on certain days can still
escape him in this blooper Dinklage can
deliver a mouth full of George RR
Martin's invented names but he can't get
a handle on a common English word no
matter how hard he tries the wise
masters of yunkai in the Camilla Verdun
and Bunnell even in the benevolent bill
a watery grave while off screen and
awaiting a spade for being arrested for
the murder of King Joffrey Tyrion has a
serious question for his brother Jaime
Lannister the punishment for regicide
drawing and quartering like any good
brother Jaime gives him the brutal truth
and apparently that truth is enough to
make Tyrion lose control of his bladder
drawing and quartering he's heading
pound verse acts in a sixth season of
Game of Thrones The Hound played by Rory
McCann has been taken under the wing of
Ian McShane kind brother ray in one
scene the Hound is hard at work chopping
wood while brother ray walks up to talk
to him the final cut has an effortlessly
slicing log but behind the scenes it
didn't go so smoothly
who believes in your seven strong and
silent esteemed British actor Charles
dance well well cast as the mighty an
imposing patriarch Tywin Lannister as
one of the finest actors of his
generation he gives even the most
dramatic scripts a little something
extra
that's probably what people on set
thought damsel doing when he took a long
thoughtful pause during a scene was he
acting nope
trying to say some things with me what
do I say
well
wedding date maybe forgetting a line and
making it look like really good acting
runs in the Lannister family when Tywin
asks his daughters Cersei Lannister when
her wedding would be thirsty pauses for
some of that Lannister dramatic effect
when would the wedding take place in
your mind
it seems that like her on-screen dad she
just happens to look super serious when
she's trying to think of her lines
Lannister lingo on the other side of the
coin actors are just as liable to say
too many words at one time and deliver a
bunch of gibberish in this blooper it
happened to Nikolaj coster-waldau when
called out on violating a promise Jaime
Lannister has the perfect excuse
jong-kook my middle name burning back
somebody almost got fired for this
mistake literally while filming a scene
is over in Martell actor Pedro Pascal
leaned against the wall a little too
close to where a torch was burning
unlike a lot of other things on Game of
Thrones that torch was not CGI it was
real fire and as Pascal is reminded
fires hot polite flub in what's supposed
to be a serious conversation between
Jaime Lannister and Brienne of Tarth
Nikolaj coster-waldau is delivering his
lines normally right up to the point he
realizes he's saying totally the wrong
thing that flub doesn't make co-star
Gwendoline Christie breakout into
laughter what does his coster-waldau is
genuine heartfelt apology for messing up
the scene nice dog hasn't been seen
since a father was killed what do you
think of him to another song I'm sorry
dance party Tyrians trial for the murder
of Joffrey was a serious moment in
season four but during their entrance
Tyrion and Jaime just couldn't help
lightening the mood in the full song and
dance number their floor show continues
all the way into the courtroom and to
helmet guards behind Tyrion are even
framed just like backup dancers too bad
tearing his case could be decided by a
dance-off
thanks for watching click the looper
icon and subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all the cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]